movie paths a popular movie ticket
subscription subscription service admits
it's looking at ways to gather private
information on its more than 2 million
users last week CEO Mitch Lowe said we
watch how you drive from home to the
movies we watch where you go afterwards
we know all about you
the company says the comments were meant
to be well jovial Jamie yuccas is in Los
Angeles was why privacy advocates are
not so amused Jamie good morning good
morning for about $10 a month movie pass
users can see a movie a day at
participating theaters now while that
may sound like a great deal it turns out
that you may also be giving up part of
your privacy to use the service movie
pass is often described as Netflix for
movie goers and makes money by
collecting subscription fees the company
now says location-based marketing could
help it generate more revenue during a
forum called data is the new oil how
will movie pass monetize it
CEO Mitch Lowe reportedly said we get an
enormous amount of information you are
being tracked in your GPS by the phone
Lowe also spoke about the importance of
data mining in this interview last week
it's a real big part and the way we will
use it is to help the studio's know who
should what who wants to watch a
particular film it's not a pass
it's spyware Jamie Cort president of
consumer watchdog says people can limit
how much personal information their
mobile phones reveal by changing the
settings on their location services why
is it a problem for movie paths to know
where we're at
we're signing up for free movies and
this just shows there are no free movies
it's probably about the restaurant that
you went to beforehand and how you got
to that restaurant and how you're
getting home from the movie exactly it's
good chinco Cheng that's how this
company's going to make money movie
passes the latest tech company to face a
backlash over data collection after a
public outcry in August Hoover said it
would stop tracking riders for up to 5
minutes after their trip ended in
December we reported on Google home and
Amazon echo consumer watchdog warned
they could become listening devices a
claim both companies denied almost
feels a little bit like big brother-ish
data is the lifeblood of so much of
Silicon Valley wired editor-in-chief
Nicholas Thompson a CBS News contributor
says tech companies collect personal
information not only to make money but
also to make their services more
efficient for customers and the problem
is that a lot of these companies that
are getting our data aren't I don't know
totally clear totally honest totally
open about it so that's a big issue the
company's privacy policy says it doesn't
collect location information until a
theater is selected a company
spokesperson told CBS News it will never
sell that data and movie pass did update
its iOS app overnight and it says that
it now removes unused app location
capability but the company says the app
operates the same way as it did
yesterday and that users will not notice
a difference Nora alright Jamie thank
you you know it's not just that app I'm
right so many other apps Google anytime
you have location services set up I feel
like we all need a privacy audit to just
hand over all our things and have
somebody tell us how much of ourselves
we've given up and given away exactly I
think Mitchell o is going just kidding
just kidding jk jk but i think anytime
you're on the internet i don't know how
you expect any kind of privacy mindful
of that you can't be just kidding when
it's your business model that's true
well I think he may regret and rethink
those words today what he spoke the
truth yes he did
he did speak soon